de tous les systèmes politiques notre
démocratie à l'occidentale apparaît
comme le plus juste de tous les systèmes
ou pour reprendre churchill le moins
mauvais une idée selon laquelle l'état
démocratique est un but à atteindre pour
toutes les sociétés
ultime solution pour s'extraire du monde
sauvage dans cette perspective
pas étonnant donc de faire remonter
l'origine de notre démocratie progrès
l'ancien et à la cité d'athènes
marketing de la société humaniste
ouverte et glorieuse c'est en tout cas
ce qu'en pense gérard collomb ministre
de l'intérieur dans un de ses discours
il nous explique que les athéniens sont
de paisibles philosophe épris d'art et
de culture
faisant face aux spartiates qui sont
atroces guerrier sanguinaire et
tyrannique
est ce qu'on retiendra de l'histoire
c'est atteignent la glorieuse
ce n'est pas par de la guerrière parce
que ceux celles qui a inventé la culture
dans le monde qui fait que l'humanisme
sur lequel nous vivons aujourd'hui est
né là-bas avec la démocratie
mais si on oublie ce cours d'histoire
pour les devils généreusement prodigués
par notre ami j'ai la déglingue
on peut toutefois remarquer que cet
extrait témoigne de manière générale de
notre européocentrisme quand il s'agit
de l'histoire et des idées bonjour à
tous ravis de retrouver dans cette
émission les premiers vous savez cette
playlist que j'ai complètement délaissé
depuis un an alors très bien mais les
premiers ou des premières quoi et bien
aujourd'hui on va parler des premières
démocraties autrement appelé les
démocraties primitive
c'est parti nous faisons effectivement
remonté l'invention de la démocratie au
grec ancien et en particulier aux
athéniens on enseigne dans les écoles
quand 508 avant jésus-christ les
réformes de clisthène et c'est dans un
premier temps d'empêcher le retour de la
tyrannie en créant des institutions au
rôle bien séparées pour permettre au
plus grand nombre de participer à la
politique
le système est complété avec le mr une
aide financière pour le citoyen qui
perdait sa journée de travail en se
rendant à l'assemblée la grèce apparaît
donc comme le berceau de la démocratie
et pour cause ce sont eux qui l'ont
nommé democracia ce que notre ami gg
nous rappelle avec son sens de la nuance
inégalable
pourtant athènes il n'y avait que 30 à
40 mille citoyens soit 10 à 15% de la
population qui exerçait véritablement de
pouvoir les autres femmes [ __ ]
esclaves n'ont pas le droit de
participer à la vie de la cité
pour l'antiquité vous allez me dire
c'est déjà pas si mal on sortait de la
tyrannie ou de l'oligarchie c'est à dire
quelques aristocrates qui se partagent
le pouvoir et on ne pouvait pas
immédiatement adopté un modèle
démocratique dans le sens moderne du
terme
en y regardant un petit peu plus
attentivement et n'en déplaise à gg il
existe pourtant bien des sociétés
démocratiques qui pourrait disputer aux
grecs la primauté du concept
certaines d'entre elles ont été nommées
par les anthropologues des démocraties
primitive
alors c'est quoi une démocratie
primitive c'est une organisation
politique dans laquelle on retrouve deux
choses essentielles
premièrement une assemblée populaire qui
est souveraine souveraine ça veut dire
que c'est elle qui décide de la guerre
et de la paix que ces décisions de son
imité par aucun autre pouvoir
contrairement à notre assemblée qui peut
être consulté par le président de la
république
deuxièmement d'échecs qui conduisent la
guerre mais détail important qui la
financent avec leurs propres moyens des
moyens privés donc car il n'y a pas de
continuer
puisque la guerre est financé par les
chefs eh bien il n'y a pas de service
militaire obligatoire et rien n'est mis
à leur disposition par l'assemblée ils
doivent convaincre les guerriers les
accompagner grâce à leur art oratoire
mais aussi grâce à leur prestige un
système plutôt intéressant non mais donc
qui vit de cette façon les anciens
germain les gaulois qui vécurent entre
le 3e et le 2e siècle avant notre ère
par exemple mais ceux pour lesquels nous
avons le plus de documentation ce sont
les iroquois les iroquois sont des
indiens d'amérique du nord qui vive
historiquement au bord du lac ontario et
du fleuve saint laurent
ils ont mis en place cette forme
d'organisation politique qu'on vient de
décrire un système démocratique à la
grecque ou une partie de la population
délibère et vote dans ce système toutes
les décisions reviennent à l'assemblée
il faut qu'il y ait unanimité pour
valider une décision ne partent à la
guerre que ceux qui le veulent les chefs
ne peuvent pas forcer les hommes à se
battre sans leur consentement
plus à l'ouest chez les indiens des
plaines cette fois ci on complète la
démocratie primitive chargée uniquement
des affaires guerrière par une
institution qui est chargé en peine de
chasse de faire régner l'ordre
sept centres de police sert
essentiellement à éviter que des petits
malins ne fasse fuir tout troupeau de
bisons
on a ici les prémices d'un état avec une
organisation de la violence mais pour
une période réduite dans l'année l'état
n'est en somme pour les anthropologues
avec la création d'un ministère de
l'intérieur qui s'extrait nécessairement
du contrôle démocratique pour protéger
justement les intérêts de l'état
en réalité mène au régime moderne ne
sont pas pleinement démocratique tous
les états quelle que soit leur forme
qu'on puisque toujours une partie du
pouvoir au peuple
pourtant déclaré souverain le mandat qui
est délivré à nos élus qui paraît
vocable les autorise dans une certaine
mesure a décidé seul ou en tout cas avec
leurs adjoints sans revenir
systématiquement devant le peuple c'est
à dire l'ensemble des citoyens
démocratie ou non des tacons puisque
toujours une partie du pouvoir du peuple
donc mais si on veut trouver une forme
de souveraineté populaire plus abouti
peut-être doit-on se tourner vers la
société
sans état oui oui sans état alors ça
peut paraître évident d'avoir une police
une administration et des impôts à payer
mais cette forme d'organisation
politique est très récent dans
l'histoire d'humanité et c'est loin
d'être la seule option possible pour
vivre en société
et d'ailleurs le fait que nous ne soyons
pas capables de qualifier ces sociétés
ayant une autre forme d'organisation
autrement qu'en employant la négative
sans état en dit d'ailleurs long sur
notre incapacité à penser en dehors de
ce cadre
bon mais qu'est ce qu'une société sans
état c'est une société sans loi et sans
roi comme les décrivait les premiers
européens qui débarquèrent dans les
nouveaux mondes
un état peut être définie par deux
choses une souveraineté sur un
territoire précis une force publique qui
détient le monopole de la violence
les sociétés sans état à la différence
des iroquois du 19e ou de la république
française actuel ne présente pas ses
caractéristiques le territoire n'y est
pas toujours précisément établie il n'y
a pas de monopole de la violence
autrement dit il n'ya ni frontière ni
police il y à un anthropologue français
pierre clastres qui a beaucoup travaillé
sur ces questions
pour lui cette absence d'état n'est pas
un manque une insuffisance de la société
qui ne parviendraient pas à penser
l'organisation collective
au contraire cette absence d'état serait
même le résultat de mécanismes élaborés
pour empêcher l'état d'apparaître
on a vu juste avant que les étapes qu'on
puisque toujours une petite partie du
pouvoir au peuple
ne serait-ce que celui de rendre justice
de punir on peut donc considérer avec
noah l'imax east pardon nos camarades
que l'état dans sa forme la plus basique
est un moyen de coercition c'est-à-dire
un pouvoir de contrainte
l'état peut vous obliger à faire
certaines choses sous peine de sanctions
alors évidemment il faut pas résumer
l'action de l'état au simple usage de la
force
n'est ce pas gg ça permet de mettre sur
pied la sécurité sociale les services
publics et des tas d'autres choses mais
dans sa définition première l'apparition
de l'état c'est l'apparition de la
contrainte dans la société contre l'état
un texte absolument essentiel en
anthropologie pierre clastres en se
basant sur l'exemple des sociétés
d'amazonie les yanomami les toupies
guarani et sur son terrain et plus
graphique chez les gars qui du paraguay
développe sa théorie sur les mécanismes
de nonnes apparition de l'état les
sociétés sans état ne sont pas des
sociétés sans chef et en revanche les
chefs ne dispose d'aucune autorité de
qu'un pouvoir de coercition d'aucun
moyen de donner un ordre
s'il tente de contraindre sa tribu à
faire quelque chose contre son gré une
guerre par exemple elle abandonne
purement et simplement ce n'est pas le
chef qui contrôle la société
mais la société qui contrôle le chef et
qui peut le renvoyer à tout moment au
moindre échec
belle leçon de souveraineté populaire
n'a par contre faut pas croire que les
sociétés sans état soit des sociétés
individualistes où chacun peut faire les
choses comme il l'entend et donner son
avis sur tout pour changer les choses
dans la société
c'est même tout le contraire en fait il
est impossible de s'y distinguer
socialement d'y introduire du changement
il existe quelques statuts sociaux des
cases pré établi si vous préférez dans
lesquels il faut saint céré avec un
système aussi rigide l'autonomie est
sacrifiée au profit de la communauté
la société se reproduit donc de manière
pratiquement immuable à travers le temps
respecter la tradition la réelle
souveraineté du peuple est à ce prix là
pierre clastres nous dit donc et c'est
tout l'enjeu de cette vidéo que l'état
n'est pas le destin de toutes les
sociétés les sociétés sans état ne sont
pas les embryons retardataires des
sociétés zulte harry
ce n'est pas parce que certaines
sociétés humaines ont choisi d'emprunter
la voie étatiques que toutes doivent
nécessairement suivre leur exemple
c'est la même chose dans d'autres
domaines votre modèle d'évolution n'est
pas le seul possible pour l'humanité
pensez à l'agriculture par exemple il
n'y a pas non plus un stade primitif qui
serait celui des chasseurs cueilleurs et
un stade développés qui serait celui des
agriculteurs
certaines civilisations sont passés de
l'un à l'autre d'autres nous d'autres
encore sont revenus à la cueillette
après avoir adopté l'agriculture il n'y
a pas de lois de l'évolution des
sociétés tous les cueilleurs de manioc
sans états n'ont pas forcément envie de
devenir comme nous des citoyens de
planteurs de betteraves ou préférez quoi
vous le manioc ou la betterave
[Musique]